si on laisse courir à ruiner vos salades
là on va choisir on va choisir
excusez moi je vous ai écoutés vous avez
bien préparer votre laissez moi vous
répondent c'est bon c'est jean paul
dessy si on laisse courir si on laisse
courir le virus c'est simple quand on a
quand on a décidé de confiner paris la
premier confinement qu'entendait
dessinée il restait plus que deux ligues
de réanimation pour l'île de france 2 il
fallait absolument confiner le pays
1 et là on sait très bien on sait très
bien que les jeunes souffrent mais je
voudrais juste un exemple
avant-hier les jeux de vision des jeunes
de 18 ans les jeunes de 18 ans qui ont
fait secteurs qui ont fêté
l'anniversaire de deux mondes
il était tout une case confère
déversèrent de leurs copains de 18 ans
y'a quand même à neuf quand le candidat
maintenant et est là et il y en a deux
et y en a deux teasers sont vraiment pas
bien quand vous aviez 20 ans vous auriez
m ont fermé toute la journée
non mais attendez docteur en ce moment
vous exercez votre profession et il ya
des gens de 35 ans qui vont mourir parce
qu'ils ne peuvent plus exercer leur
profession parce que des gens de 85 ans
il y en a 45 ans qui a relevé la qualité
de vie de 4,1 pour cent sont en train de
mourir pour une maladie qui n'est pas
plus dangereuse qu'une autre
ça fait un an et demi que des gens comme
vous des cloques tentera de nous
enfermer au prétexte que la maladie est
la chose la plus grave du monde et
qu'ils elles cette maladie s'appelle
locaux vides et pour des raisons
sanitaires
vous êtes en train d'oublier toutes les
autres maladies mentales cérébrale
psychologique qui font des ravages jeu
il y en a quatre en oublier il y en a qu
il y en a un qui a pas oublié les
maladies mentales je pense parce que
c'est macron quand il a décidé de pas
confiné parce que là on sait on sait
qu'actuellement je vous fais le virus le
virus il est on est sur un plafond ce
sera new qui est raide un plateau qui
est très très élevé mais qui est mon
corps accepte habré mais il a pensé que
comme dans les eaux usées le virus
baisse et qu'il va y avoir les vacances
scolaires qui vont couper une partie de
l'épidémie il va y avoir à peut-être un
petit trou de souris ça dans lequel on
va passer parce que ce qu'il a entendu
c'est que effectivement en france il ya
énormément de maladie mentale
il ya des romans de chanter leur hymne
et et figurez-vous que j'envoie
quelques-uns dans mon cabinet du docteur
j'ai appelé mon
que je vous apprécie vraiment vous le
savez j'ai du respect proudhon classé
suivent et non par peu par rapport aussi
c'est pas du tout personnel j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour vous je vais
quand même vous dire une chose
l'agacement quand beaucoup de jeunes
c'est que le discours que vous tenez ce
soir il est ce qu'il est c'est à dire
c'est un discours médical mais ce n'est
pas de votre faute
j'aimerais vous mettre en garde contre
une chose c'est le fait que nous sommes
saturés par ce discours de spécialistes
dont un qui nous donne l'impression
qu'on fait du ski nautique derrière le
virus que c'est le virus qui nous dicte
nos lois alors moi je voudrais bien
entendre ce que vous dites mais six
adore ça dure encore six ans au bout
d'un moment on va être obligé de dire
stop c'est à dire que les nommer
monsieur de ferran ça va pas durer six
ans déjà et en disant je vous explique
sa fille non mais ça va pas pourquoi ça
n'a pas duré six ans parce que pourquoi
pourquoi il faut arrêter ce virus parce
que déjà il ya des variants le variant
brésilien on n'est pas certain que les
vaccins actuels sont efficaces bien
heureusement
heureusement que techniquement
maintenant grâce aux arn messager on
peut va pouvoir adapter le virus étant
on va pouvoir adapter les vaccins avec
une application est seulement là ce que
ce que moi honnêtement je pensais qu'on
serait peinard cet été mais un c'est bon
si le virus à se calmer seulement
l'apparition des variants fait qu'on
réfléchisse autrement je pense
sincèrement qu'on pourra vraiment
respirer on va respirer cet été parce
qu'on va vivre nord et cetera on va
commencer à respirer en avril mais ça
sera plus soutenable peut-être que les
restaurants pour rouvrir en terrasse
parce qu'en soirée rendez compte que
c'est peut-être tuer les gens mais parce
que mes parents n'en sais rien c'est pas
regarder ce qui s'est passé que le
variant angles est là on entend de
s'emmerder en train de faire des
séquençages machin mais là les gamins
ils n'étaient pas touchées de la
première vague là maintenant il ya des
classes entières qui sont touchés alors
ok alors
un truc que vous vouliez vraiment sorti
il y a dans cette dans ce début de
siècle quelque chose qui me consterne
c'est à dire que et ça c'est pas de
votre faute si une vision sans doute
scientiste du monde qui revient comme on
en a eu dix neuvième siècle qui est que
la mort est devenu quelque chose de
parfaitement scandaleux
la mort et devient presque illégitime
devient presque illégale et c'est devenu
le grand tabou la société il ya eu une
époque on avait peur de nos morts
maintenant on a peur de nos vivants
c'est à dire que les vivants sont
tétanisés à l'idée de ne pas rentrer
chez eux le soir en sortant le matin
parce qu'ils vont peut-être se fait
renverser alors on fera un procès à
l'état parce que les routes sont pas
entretenues de chopé un virus et on fera
un procès à l'état parce que l'autre
l'état n'a pas pu anticiper quelque
chose qui était quasiment pas
anticipable et donc si vous voulez il ya
un mélange de procédure aille à sion
perpétuel et de d'assainissement de la
réalité on veut absolument tout lycée
pour que plus rien ne soit dangereux